pour allonger la ligne bleue du métro
jusqu'à anjou en préparant cette annonce
tout le monde savait qu'il y avait du
scepticisme dans l'air fait que ça va
tous faire wilquin temps commence par
construire en était un serbe et je vous
assure que cette fois ci c'est la bonne
quelques rires jaunes dans la salle
puisque la première annonce remonte à
rené lévesque en 1979 c'est finalement
un demi siècle plus tard en 2029 que la
mise en service est désormais prévue au
total cinq stations verront le jour la
nouveauté du projet c'est le futur
terminus des accès à la station seront
construites de chaque côté de
l'autoroute
une manière de mieux desservir l'est et
de ne pas trop empiéter sur les galeries
d'anjou ce qui fait économiser des
centaines de millions de dollars le shaq
et d'un hammam bravo l'entrejeu même si
on creuse déjà dans le secteur pie-ix
pour connecter le srb et la future
station l'appel pour faire venir un
tunnelier qui parcourera 6 km
principalement sous jean talon est prêt
à être lancé le patron de la stm dresse
la liste des bénéfices
25600 supplémentaires en point dans la
section du prolongement seulement pour
la circulation 5300 automobile de moins
sur les routes pour la planète c'est 25
tonnes de gs ii - par heure de points
le prolongement de la ligne bleue qu'on
annonce aujourd'hui ça démontre de façon
très très réel ce que ça donne quand
tout le monde est autour de la table une
allusion aux embûches dans la
planification du rem de l'est quant à la
question du budget 6 milliards 400
millions de dollars ça ne doit plus être
un frein selon trajectoire québec on
s'inquiète pas vraiment du prix des
infrastructures routières camp pour
faire surfer sur koffi personnes
s'inquiètent du coût alors en transport
collectif c'est 56 milliards 56
milliards ça va avoir des retombées
économiques qui est très important
aucune station de métro n'a été
inaugurée sur l'île de montréal depuis
1988 même si on ne compte plus les
annonces officielles similaire à celle
d'aujourd'hui tout le monde veut croire
que cette fois c'est effectivement la
bonne
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal